well the man overseeing our future
relationship with the eu the chancellor
of the dutch of lancaster cabinet office
minister michael goff
joins us in the studio good to see you
this morning good morning
we should say this is a moment of
significance isn't it an agreement in
principle
on that rather phony issue of the irish
border yes absolutely
uh throughout this year there have been
intense talks between
ourselves and the european commission in
order to make sure that we can resolve
the issues
on what's called the northern ireland
protocol and of course people wanted to
make sure
first of all that there was no border
infrastructure on northern ireland
island border but also that northern
ireland can be a secure part of the
united kingdom
we've agreed that uh as a result some of
the uh the measures that we were putting
forward which
some in europe had criticized we can now
no longer
we no longer need to introduce those um
and that means that uh
there is a smoother glide path towards a
possible deal
it could be viewed as a concession being
made on the british part
given at the threat that we had made to
break international law so what have we
gained from making this concession
well unless we'd secured agreement um on
the northern ireland protocol
then we faced a situation where goods
going to northern ireland would have
faced
tariffs and the price of everything from
a pint of milk to a nissan qashqai
would have been greater for citizens in
northern ireland uh it's also the case
that we might have faced restrictions on
some of the food that would have been
found on supermarket shelves
it would also have been the case that
there might have been barriers that
people would have
would have tried to erect between
northern ireland businesses
and great britain none of those threats
now exist and as a result
of the uh determined way um in which the
prime minister has negotiated
are we're in a stronger position to be
able to say to the people of northern
ireland that they are secure in the
united kingdom
but also of course all the gains of the
peace process over the last 22 years
are secured as well it does though very
much look like
a border down the irish sea there will
be checks
minimal checks perhaps but there will be
checks between great britain
and northern ireland and wasn't it boris
johnson you said that you know over my
dead body
there would be a border in the irish sea
i don't think there's a border in the
irish sea
what are the checks taking place there
it's always been the case that uh
the whole island of ireland has been
regarded as a single zone when it comes
to
to animal health and it's always been
the case that there's been
uh checks on live animals when they've
gone from greek britain
to northern ireland uh there are minimal
additional number of checks
on products of animal origin and we put
this forward
um during the talks last year
as a way of breaking the deadlock and
making sure that we could avoid
any sort of border infrastructure on the
island of ireland as well
but the the impact for businesses and
for citizens in northern ireland
will be minimal citizens are going to be
able to enjoy all the products that they
currently enjoy
and the security of knowing that their
position within the united kingdom is
absolutely stable the
the checks may well be minimal and we
will discover this as as we move forward
but
but they remain checks and they remain
border checks and there is a difference
it would be it has to be said now
between great britain
and northern ireland in terms of its
long-lasting relationship with the
european union i mean let's not forget
we're also going to have not eu
officials stationed in northern ireland
now
by my reading and perpetuity well there
are two things to say
the first thing is that that northern
ireland's position is different from the
rest of the united kingdom and one
particular way
which is that it has a land border with
the european union um and as a result of
that
there are certain specific additional
measures that we need to put in place
and also it has been the case that
northern ireland's position ever since
the signing of the belfast
agreement um has been uh unique in the
united kingdom
but it's firmly part of the uk and the
principle of consent underlies this
as for eu officials it's always the case
when you have trade arrangements
that people from another country with
whom you've got a trading relationship
can come can inspect and can make sure
that your facilities
meet their standards and vice versa why
then
is it that unionists in northern ireland
who are arguably best placed
to decide whether or not there is a
border down the irc
are less than sanguine about a long-term
eu presence in northern ireland
and indeed about the potential of there
being different regulatory regimes
there and here well i think when we
started this whole process
uh we wanted to make sure that we uh uh
respected the uh position of both
traditions in northern ireland
um now i'm a unionist myself i want to
make sure that uh uh northern ireland
stays part of the united kingdom
and i'll argue for the benefits of that
but it's also the case that over time
we've acknowledged
that there are some specific provisions
that exist in northern ireland
that that take account of the fact that
it has a border with uh the republic
and with the european union but if we
were to draw a venn diagram of the uk
and the european union northern ireland
would in essence be the bit where the
the two intersect right now you said to
my colleague sam quotes yesterday look
this provides northern ireland with with
the best of both worlds
here he asked the same question that i'm
going to ask right now why not the best
of both worlds for
scotland england wales if it's good
enough for northern ireland
why not the rest of us well as you point
out there are some people in northern
ireland who
are critical of some some aspects of
what we've achieved and feel that uh
there are downsides to this it is a
balanced package
overall it provides businesses in
northern ireland
with access to the single market because
again there's no border infrastructure
on the island of ireland as you pointed
out there are some additional
administrative checks uh on some goods
going
from britain to northern ireland not the
other way around um and
that that balanced package means that uh
businesses in northern ireland have
access both to the rest of the uk
and to the eu but ultimately northern
ireland's position is unique
its history its geography its politics
mean that it's in a different position
uh to the rest of the united kingdom
even as it remains
solidly part of one country what does
all this this mean for the prospect of a
trade deal certainly the mood music from
both sides
doesn't exactly lend much confidence to
the fact that we're going to get any
progress in the immediate future
but when given that what assistance is
the government preparing
for for businesses that will have a
negative impact because of a no deal
brexit
well firstly i hope that we will secure
a free trade agreement but secondly
in the event that we don't have a
negotiated agreement there are a number
of steps that the chancellor and others
can take in order to make sure
that british business is as competitive
as possible
and over the course of this year we've
been investing significant amounts in
order to help business to prepare
can we talk about vaccines because of
course yesterday was it was an
incredibly significant day and indeed
now we heard the news yesterday as well
of the
oxford vaccine ready to come on stream
now i mean first of all your
your thoughts on the fact that we are
now starting to see that roll out and
when we might actually see
other vaccines being brought on stream
well uh yesterday was a great day
um uh as we know the world was watching
as the very first vaccinations that
occurred
occurred here in the uk thanks to the
nhs
um we know that more vaccine is arriving
from the
uh uh the the the current level of
stocks which are coming from belgium
but we also know that uh the oxford
astrozenica virus
uh passed some more tests yesterday um
and i hope but again
i have to defer to the official medical
regulator uh that will be able to be
injecting people with that vaccine
soon what does this mean for the easing
of restrictions matt hancock appeared to
suggest
yesterday that when the most vulnerable
in society have received the vaccine
that is the point at which things would
start getting back to normal i mean can
you put a time scale on that
no i don't think i can at this stage i
think the most important thing is to
make sure exactly as matt outlines
that we vaccinate the most vulnerable
then we want to make sure that
vaccination spreads across the whole
population
um i think that we can begin
progressively to ease measures in the
new year
but certainly we need during january and
february which tough months for the nhs
not to relax our vigilance what what
what exactly are we expecting to happen
to the nhs
come january everyone knows you ease the
restrictions
covered transmission increases that will
happen over christmas it's a certainty
do we have any estimates of the
additional burden that's going to be
placed on the nhs
well the nhs always keeps the the level
of pressure that it's under
under review um and it's you know you're
absolutely right
uh people are going to be allowed to mix
um over christmas
uh it's a natural human desire to be
with those that we love at that time of
the year
and that's one of the reasons why we
have the tier system in place
some people have understandably uh found
the current tier system
very difficult and it is but it's there
to try to ensure
that we uh keep the pressure on the nhs
down through those difficult months
so so where then would we see the
restrictions being eased in the new year
which particular parts can we say look
that is going to be the first thing
well again this is something that we we
have to keep under review
um we know that the virus is a a
resilient and
difficult enemy we know that concerted
action in areas such as liverpool
have brought the instance down and we've
been able to ease restrictions
but we just have to keep this constantly
under review no one more than me
would like to see more and more of the
country move into lower tiers
but of course as you quite rightly point
out we need to make sure the nhs is
protected through
the next two difficult months i mean is
london about to enter
into tier three by your reckoning
certainly there are people in other
parts of the country with higher
infection rates
than there are sorry lower infection
rates that there are in part of london
pointing the finger at london and
suggesting that it's been singled out
for special treatment
no i don't think that's true i mean i
think you're right that there are
variations across london borough by
borough
uh but we get advice from the joint
biosecurity center
um and from those who are monitoring not
just the incidence of the virus but also
the pressure on the nhs
and we do keep these things under review
but of course what we want to do is to
see areas
if we possibly can either stay in their
current tier
or move down a tier but it requires us
all particularly in the right christmas
to be vigilant
it seems what you're saying there that
london might not be about to enter into
tier three there well it's not
my personal judgment it's it's you know
it's it's not the case that any
individual minister
or indeed any individual advisor decides
we look at the evidence and we form a
collective judgment and of course we
share that evidence so people can see
the basis
on which the decision was made a little
later in the program i'm going to be
speaking to fred banning and he has been
diagnosed with category four at bowel
cancer
terminal a horrible thing he is asking
for people in similar situations to him
to be prioritized for vaccinations so
that in the remaining weeks months of
his life
you can spend time with the family but
what do you make of that um well
it's an incredibly um
you know moving situation when you have
people who are living with terminal
diseases and we're
uh reviewing how we can make sure that
the most vulnerable
and those in in clinically difficult
positions can
be vaccinated and we were discussing
exactly how we can do this
in government only yesterday obviously
it depends on the number of vaccines
that we can secure
but absolutely when you have a moving
example like that and
there are all too many we want to make
sure that people are
vaccinated so they can be um with those
they love
uh at what is inevitably um an
incredibly difficult and stressful time
for
for for the family uh well i know that
fred will be keeping his fingers crossed
that there may be some movement in that
regard sometime soon
michael golf always nice to see you
thanks for joining us no no thank you
thank you